- But you ran into, recently,
(laughing)
your Mad Men co-star Jon Hamm, right?
- Yes, at the Independent
Spirit Awards. Yeah.
- Yes, okay, okay.
So he looks a little
upset in this picture.
- Yeah, I'm really not sure
what exactly what he...
- What's happening?
- I'm not sure.
He looks mad at me.
I don't know why.
- He does.
- I think he might be holding a grudge.
We used to play a lot of games on Mad Men.
- I loved this cast.
- Oh, yes.
We used to play a lot of games.
- What kind of games?
- Card games, heads up...
- Like spades, gin rummy,
like that kind of thing?
- Like speed. Do you...
- Speed! I love speed. Yes.
- Ooh, we were obsessed with speed.
- Yeah.
- And...
- I'm actually pretty good.
- Are you?
- Yeah.
- So am I.
- Yeah. Pretty good
Elizabeth, just saying.
- So am I.
- But y'all would play all the time?
- We would. We would
play games all the time.
We would literally work all day,
like many many hours for a week,
and then we would stay quite late and...
We'd stay like till like 2
in the morning sometimes.
- Oh.
- Just playing and playing and playing.
And we'd be like just one more game,
just one more game.
And we took it really really seriously.
And John and I took it very seriously.
Now one of us is a sore loser.
(laughing)
And...
- And I'm assuming it's not you.
(laughing)
- It's... You would be correct.
- That's amazing.
- And we had a championship
and we would speed and we'd play.
- A championship.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
It was a very serious championship.
And we played and we played and we played.
I did not loose.
- Yes.
- And we never played again.
- That's we he's upset.
That's why he's upset.
- He's still upset.
- You stole his speed thunder. Yes.
- Like five years ago.
- That's amazing though.